interplanetary Galactic Federation
Carmichael and Christian brought us to a
really weird place they said we got to
stop to jerk it
apparently there's alien food and other
accoutrements inside I have no idea what
this is bringing they're building a UFO
hotel cow jump out the tri-tip oh we've
killer I'll do that can taste the
abduction moon craters ugly muscle
crack moon crater track you guys want to
see something interesting you want to
see how a movie scene is shot in the
very beginning when you walk in and no
one's ready nothing's in the room is
completely empty all the way to the
final shots you're getting for your
final edit well let's find out so thanks
to carmine building in the car I can
drive the carpool lane and skip all this
traffic
but wait what's that up ahead no he's
going for it let me get back in that car
pool lane the moment I get the chance
[Music]
the most exciting thing about directing
lifeline is honestly getting the
experience of doing a professional CV
that from this point forward Sam and I
have this experience under our belt it
becomes a very very big resume research
i know it's technically not TV but it's
close enough now one itself is a is a
good script and I'm excited to make it
but in like big picture it's also like
the first step into a new phase of our
careers that's pretty exciting for us as
a director I'm going to be supervising
this entire thing
my goal is get everything up and ready
on time looking good all the excess crap
everybody in a good mood everything
looking pretty and performances on point
and hopefully everything is set up with
enough time for us to get some good
performances at experiment let's go see
how the film set actually work yeah good
mastering today starting today yeah
we're trying to match the lighting from
what we shot last week the actors come
in you watch the blocking and then I
start thinking you shot what's going to
make the most into the story and then I
bust out this program called CAD rage
which has my set of lenses trying to
camera and then I'll go around and I'll
take screen grabs of the specific shots
that I want now recording on the fly
essentially awesome yeah and so far it's
been really beneficial for us because
help us move a lot quicker always the
costume department so I'm concerned and
I'm the costume designer for lifelines
I've been doing this for five years
every single person is playing a
character double they're always could be
wearing something that either is a
collaboration of myself directors
there's writers and we all kind of come
up with what we decide that character
should look like because anyone makes a
person know though different days within
one threatens you know you wake up and
maybe you're in your pajamas having
breakfast and then you go to work that
day and then you go out that night so
someone could be and you know four
different looks throughout the day and
those are all looks that I have to
figure out and there's always it depends
on this writing something like this on
average most characters have like three
to six changes each so there's eight of
those events how do you think organized
we're all sitting photo and then little
no-self it on and then that goes on the
outfit that they're going to wear and
then you talk about nation that my
dentist was asking what I do and she's
like wait I'm so confused they don't
dress themselves looks like no no
someone else too hot well I've got you
guys here essentially the plan today is
to wish you just up until about seven
o'clock and then we move out to the curb
here on maturity so questions about that
so good all right so starting the day
the very first thing we do is blocking
and that's basically the term we use
from the actors come in and you get to
figure out where you're going to stand
or they're doing their performance so
it's a mix of direction that you give
the actors and then just feeling what's
natural for the scene first thing that
this thing starts with you with a little
notepad your hand even working out some
notes calculations actively working out
you're not just a boss talking people
like your accent doing work gentleman
comes in popular teams winning paper
employees and Maj however actually sit
down and you take a spot at the corner
method rolls around they're totally if
you get that up and taste just a little
bit here okay you know you're eager to
do to the year you're agitated but not
frustrated is just like ants you know
that's energy
maybe flipped over your notes and then
you know bring it back to her whenever
you feel like okay relevant to the beat
so after you block we figure out where
the actors are going to go throwing
marks on the floor then we'll have
stand-ins take the spots of the actors
the actors and just standing there for
half an hour while you line up the
camera standings now take the spot and
then what Adrian takes a little
viewfinder figures out where all the
cameras are going to go and we're
shooting with two cameras figures out
and a setup and a be set up for each
setup so we have a one a and a 1 B and a
2 and a 2 B 3 a and the 3 B you could
tape on the ground yes Zera cific yeah
hey should I color we've got 48
different characters and so I've
organized them each with their own
individual color or do you color the
same 40 well I have 12 colors of tape
and then I add other strips of different
colored tape to give it the 48 but yes
you put it in like a t-shape so that one
foot goes on either side of the T you
can mark the camera with a V saying like
this is where we're shooting this
direction basically - to make sure that
things are in the right place talked
about how I tried to have three
directions for a scene a direction for
my actors the directions from a crew in
a direction for the audience I want the
audience to feel like Nathan was ready
to move on to other things and so to
communicate that through body language I
decided to have them standing walking
around looking more antsy and more
active and they seen them in any
previous scene this cast that we have is
so different so my name is Usman Ali and
I'm playing Nathan I've done with him I
grew up outside of the state and I have
traveled a lot people can't necessarily
pinpoint where I'm from for who I old I
am and I didn't is something about that
that I hear 13 me I'm 30 I'm 12 but
there's something about that that I've
sort of infused into Nathan as well
there's ambiguity something that I've
been able to access because of my own
sense of feeling a little separate when
you're part of the creative process like
that some some opportunities where
ordinary nico on the guises
we're going to sit there sort of break
apart the scene and talk about what's
not working what's what is working and
any time a director allows an actor to
do that it gives you ownership you know
I mean makes you feel like you're part
of the process of creating something
I'll say something a lot of times actors
sort of high ethnicity we don't
necessarily get the opportunity to play
characters I don't have anything to do
with ours if you know means yeah so
often they're like oh we need this brown
guy to play this one I mean this is the
character that could be any ethnicity
and those roles are not open to us very
often it's slowly happening more
Morrison when I was offered the
opportunity by this role he's just a guy
named Nathan we don't know what he's
about
Lisbon's well they never bring up his
ethnicity I was like this is like a
breakthrough he doesn't require yeah
absolutely no accent and you know some
Christian and I were just talking
earlier he was a hey it'd be great for
this two of us on it so yeah you could
win same ethnicity enough this never
happens you like room for just one of us
you know well yeah we're both in this
we're both like guys who just happen to
be working at a company nothing to do
with the fact that we're they needed to
brown guys even if I start I want to
move in here it's like a movement would
be great sure and when you walk
in the consultation we do the December
set of really how fabulous acutely to
try an Italian to be a booking for the
door agent it just been poking me
feeling like so once you take a set out
then lighting knows where they're going
to light camera crew and open up at the
camera we're going to lay down some
dolly trap in this movement the crew
goes work of building all that so we
have very little reading from the top
guys what's just natural here we go
ready and I owe my loyalty is to you
Annika
you know when you said Chris buckled
under holds the arrow I don't care of a
real solid of to beat a fella Morgan
yeah way officer her so Lydia it's like
she's gonna be excited right yes yeah
ready and action action okay cool work
guys security let's just make that again
changing the path is one constant
innovation some tips we've covered all
of us James
stuff we started filming the same baby
half Margo so it's about the size of
things with into the now or flipping the
room around to look in the other
direction you covered Nathan County
moving all the gear lighting teams can
adjust lighting just a little bit we
jump right back in your operating life
and what are the eight names yeah and I
think all in all the angles are ignoring
me - you said you're a camera first if
whatever the main actors
you can pose for the ATF way be camera
jumping and get a close-up or the
additional coverage show today can we
get down like 10% on that astro yeah
yeah yeah that looks way better
okay here we go guys
for this raffle cut great get most
exciting coverage yeah can't do my like
today we dive into film noir and show
you how you can get a stylized look like
this without a green-screen I get naked
no click on the screen